this episode is presented by Ardbeg Isla
single malt scotch whiskey discover
Planet art bag today
[Music]
from the channel behind the prestige TV
you stay up to watch as an adult and the
pre-internet porn you stayed up to watch
as a kid comes HBO's return to the
wellest Rose in search of an heir to
Game of Thrones because every other
trueborn son of their parent company is
dead
House of the Dragon
remember Daenerys
girls named Khaleesi sure do turns out
she and her brother weren't the only
nuts in the Targaryen family tree as you
revisit a civil war between rival
factions of goth albino sociopaths that
only goes down because so many talks are
named aegon aegon the prince
Prince one then choose a side to root
for even though the only thing these
extremely out of touch rich people have
in common with their extremely poor
subjects is inbreeding hey Raymond come
out and look this one's got a funny eye
like you
made a whole new tomesworth of
characters trying to satisfy their
raging throwners like Prince Damon a
fully armed and operational Joffrey if
you're accusing me of some depravity
you'll need to be more specific watch
Matt Smith continue the hot streak he's
been on since Mormon time as this
homicidal narcissist with a limb noodle
that the internet has a crush on anyway
are you okay internet
viserys a stellar performance by Patty
Constantine as a king succumbing to
Parts falling off disease my own face is
no longer a handsome one who just wants
to hang out in this room and play with
his artisanal Minifigs all day he'll
declare his daughter inira as Heir a
girl who looks like she just found out
she isn't getting a pony who gets
hardened sharpen and aged about 20 years
when her bestie becomes her stepmom
rainhera must fight for women's rights
over the women's wrongs of Alison
Hightower she said
here's your son's service
your blood his last words to me and I
was the only one to hear it
[Music]
then they're supporting players like
Otto Hightower the hand of the king and
the king of the passive aggressive
remark perhaps there's some better use
for the princess's talents you're great
Kristen Cole a hardened combat veteran
yet still the most fragile White Knight
in the land spoiled
the valerians an ancient family who
bring much needed diversity to people
and ridiculous white wigs and lurking
ever lurking is Lara strong who's like
Littlefinger if he were more into little
piggies instead
[Music]
if you thought MTV's lineup was full of
hard to watch pregnancies strap in for a
show that's more comfortable with dead
moths and stillbirths than a red State
Legislature where the showrunner had to
explicitly promise to tone it down this
time and though their female characters
go through hell at least they all have
easy access to plan T it will rid you of
any unwanted consequences it's supposed
to be certain
so return to West Rose hundreds of years
before winter came all over it but don't
worry the baratheons are still dumb
where's the bloody maester the Starks
are still loyal there has never lived a
stark who forgotten oath Lannister smog
targaryen's cuckoo the episodes directed
by Miguel sapotnik impossible to see and
now more than ever the dragon's enormous
ex machina is that keep surprising
people despite being as big and loud as
a 747.
there we go that's the writing quality
we got used to starting to feel like old
times again Danny kind of forgot about
the iron Fleet
starring the leprechaun Matt Damon
you're an uncle lover yes it's true
nobody loves uncles quite Like You It's
Not Easy Being Green the queen who never
guessed The Dread pirate cordless King
Louis of CK you'll pay for this Potter
Hollywood's worst Chris Prince Eric
that's what I do I lurk and I tow things
the lion creeps tonight luceris looking
like a snack
meeting balls I wonder what those are
for oh
a human spoiler alert you are the best
a Morton Joe's Crab Shack and calling
someone a without really saying it
sooner let's make it what it looks like
you there's a note does he oh strong
does your brother mention if this one
also Bears a market but entirely
coincidental resemblance to the command
of the city watch here's Leno's son what
grounds could there be indeed Lord
beesbury but indeed come on you know you
want to say it our children
oh
he said it you were in so much trouble
Wrigley blonde
icon foresaw the end of the world of men
just to begin with a terrible winter and
if the world of managed to survive a
Targaryen must be seated on the iron
throne and actually all you really need
is a stark with two Working Hands
so which shows off to a better start
Game of Thrones or the Hot D we counted
up every kill lie and beer in the first
season to see who takes the crown in a
brand new episode of by the Numbers
click the thumbnail on the right to
watch now this episode was presented by
ORD big Isla single malt scotch whiskey
a whiskey out of this world awaits you
on planet orbeg